but i want to apology from all you guys
for what because
at the beginning of the year they asked
me who i would start a team with
with i said bo bo and all you guys
laughed at me all you guys laughing
i'm thinking i'm a rookie i'm on a
bandwagon yeah when i said ball boy
i'll tell you what i looked over at the
sticky notes i saw that you have a
sticky note that says the pelicans are
going to get the eight seat
so there's still a chance that you're
going to be right on that one listen i'm
telling you uh
i had the opportunity to coach bobo with
my son
and him and my son are similar very
talented but when you jump on them
they go to work so him and my son went
out with soldier boy one night
before a game so i had to suspend him
and i was a barnum and i told them if
y'all don't do certain things next game
y'all off the team when i tell you bull
ball was doing stuff i never seen before
i was like yo this kid right here has it
right and and i'm glad he's with a guy
like mike malone because mike speaks our
language
michael's gonna bring him along slow and
you know let him do what he wanted to do
i saw a a floppy down where he came up
and shot the three
that was crazy yeah i was like he was in
the corner
i'm so happy bringing this up because
i've been telling jeremy and everybody
we need to talk about bowl balls
because what we're seeing is amazing
but that's the easiest one what about
the football coming off the sound screen
that's true
he has a handle